j'accueille maintenant chantal goya
bonsoir à la vessie voilà il aime
beaucoup chantal goya tous envie de
baiser chantal vers l'interview de là
c'est le travail d'avants après on va se
détendre bordel
oui bien sûr il va faire une artère
bouchée d'un sérieux surtout quelque
chose elle est la double promo nous
devons voir ou pas les attroupements
trible bromo ouais mais j'en connais
deux mois j'ai des gens qui font un
double album moi j'ai le vif qui
s'appelle la niaque est une
autobiographie
et puis le lycée des idées il fallait
décoré à noël alors bien entendu bah oui
bah oui c'est sûr il faisait écho liste
veut céder le cdc un best-of ses dessins
des stocks étaient gâtés d'avoir des
impacts à munich afin nancy réclame
et qui peut deviner ce qu'il a envie de
manger rien faire pour moi c'est du
poisson ci réclame convoyer fermé alors
le cd donc chez un best-of et le dvd
c'est le spectacle mystérieux voyage de
marie rose
alors on va on va commencer par le
best-of voilà vous voulez écouter les
chansons de chantal goya dj
la fille son bac quelle chance
oui
il
les ensembles
je
venir
oui
voilà ça va c
le croire
vous savez
oui
louviers
et
c'est pas
au jeu
je peux vous dire
et
la fille
il fait
oui
il
füle
c'est quoi
en bas
comment
hu
chantal goya le best-of
on se croirait au queen's ouais alors
dans ce possible au frais qu'est-ce qui
a le rang on me dit qu'il faut tout
refaire
non on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
chantal goya bonsoir il ya une caméra
sur alain chabat si vous pouvez me fit
delcassé joffre ça noël à ta famille
parce que bien sûr parfois tu déconne
mais parfois ça d'avellino accéléré dj
non
oui
et là
m
bien alors maintenant on passe aux tv
gaydailles mystérieux voyage de marie
rose c'est quoi le pitch d'un petit
garçon qui est samedi soir vrai qu'il
est arrivé quand il était pensionnaire
qui était tombé dans une dans un lac
glacé et évidemment ce petit garçon d'un
mois je suis celle qui va le retrouver
et je me bats contre les quatre éléments
du monde à terre le feu l'eau et l'air
avec des enfants alors la terre on va
sous la terre on recompte des rares et
trop violent pour toi mais tu vas t'y
faire des bijoux séditieux dans le
royaume des pâquerettes
c'est bisounours quand j'arrive leur
adresse dans les bras d'un dragon bleu
qui ne portent dans l'air il m'a même
sous la mère j'en étais drogue qui
voudra encore les charmes et essence et
diesel égal à la 84 20 ans pile de votre
caméra chantal magnéto serge les chiens
ils veulent vous le fassiez que les
oreilles de lapin mais qu elle entend
les chiens